they're already banning people and i can
already see it there
there's going to be some kind of
blackout i look i don't know i don't i
don't know exactly what's going to
happen because you know obviously we're
going to be streaming so we'll be
talking about something here on this
show i mean
every just imagine from bandwidth
perspective of every user every big user
on these platforms is going to be live
all at the same time
that's probably the best safeguard we
have for any kind of
you know it's the only one scams or
dirty games the only one but i mean you
look at how they how they
just you totally i don't even want to
say erased but
hunter biden doesn't exist as far as the
media can is concerned right
and most people know about it i'm not
sure everyone cares i think
conservatives and trump supporters are
like look at this
and the anti-trump people are like i
literally don't care
and i think i think that really does
explain a lot of
both sides either you like trump things
doing a good job and the other side
really really hates him and you know
both
i do think i think the hunter biden
stuff and i say this is someone who's
been
you know all up in that hard drive um
i know right that what it did was it
changed the tenor of a
of the race because it almost made trump
not the incumbent
because prior to that trump had been
running as the incumbent i'm the
president joe biden's the challenger
right
but it changed the framing of the race
that trump is an outs is now the
outsider again and biden is the swamp
yes it brought it it aligned biden with
the swamp
in a way that his strategy of sort of
being quiet laying low had really
prevented
any serious vigorous uh examination of
his
of his time and his family's time and
business which by the way
these were originally um examinations
and observations and investigations that
were done by the bernie bros right this
was this was a thing of the left and you
can go back
to all of those different memes and
and videos that came out during the
primaries and this this was
not from the right at all like these
were lefties talking about joe biden his
family
they were calling joe biden demented it
was the progressive saying joe biden was
had dementia
and of course conservatives have long
been saying it too
but now all of a sudden the tune is
changing now biden's no it's not he's
fine it's like bro that was you on
camera what like seven months ago
saying the dude's out of his mind now
now it's like you forgot you have them
do you have any
you have dementia yeah maybe they have
maybe they're all
amnesiac or whatever the word is oh i
think they're certainly amnesic about
kamala harris it's like
your your party rejected her so
forcefully remember she didn't even uh
tulsi gabbard won more delegates than
kamala harris
but it was like one delegate wasn't it
right but kamala was one zero right
right so and it was definitely her
family or excuse me her party
that that rejected her and now all of a
sudden but you know she's also being
very quiet as well she does like that
one video every day
walking off of a private jet with like a
different pair of shoes on
yeah and they and they yeah she does
like boomerang she's keeping boomerang
business
and then she just disappears and that's
it i think she's gone i i think
i just need to say it there is this one
thing that joe biden is offering us
that trump never could actually there's
two things there's two very important
things let's go
true and nana true and anonymous
pressure
and better cath care now listen on a
shout out to depression
true in an honor to pressure okay i have
no idea what that gibberish was supposed
to be
i have no idea what vodka care is
supposed to be either and normally
journalists
in the in the media they they do
something they translate for joe biden
i actually tried to do that with the
first one
true and international something
pressure i think it was true
international cooperation under pressure
okay yeah okay but listen listen so you
speak fluent biden
i try it's like he makes speech typos
yes he does
he really does literally yeah and we're
banned
so uh but what's batacath care i don't
know i think it's a mix of
biden healthcare obamacare and
healthcare
and and bath and body
basic body i don't know
maybe it's an acronym i bring that up
just to say
i can't believe we're actually in a
timeline or whatever
where you have did you see what happened
today with joe biden at the michigan
rally
obama had to call him out three times
and he just like was was that real or
was that edited
because i i saw that one and now like
the one with this tampa thing that came
up it's like
i don't know about tampa no well no it
was that that one was edited that was a
defense
that actually was so yeah this thing
where
it sounded like which was it he's he's
clearly not
in tampa but he's saying that he's in
tampa but he's in minnesota and somebody
deep
faked the like logo to say minnesota or
to say tampa and then depict the one
behind him to say tampa and it was
really good wow
it was really really good and it was it
was totally fake it was
absolutely fake that's disappointing
because you don't need to do that with
biden right you really have plenty of
just right which is why
a lot of people shared it right and it
just went off i didn't share it myself
but now i'm like questioning every even
a little thing like that like i wanted
i don't know i just i want to see like a
full clip you know that you know that
viral video of the leftists calling for
a coup have you seen that one
the one with like they're all like
federal workers in a zoom call oh yeah
yeah yeah i was actually i was actually
on their zoom call yesterday oh really
yeah
are they really calling it a coup uh
in in that video they were the one i was
in they didn't they were just talking
about direct action did you see the full
video though
because i don't think they were calling
what they were doing a coup i think what
she was saying was
trump is staging a coup
because uh makes no sense for someone to
be like we're going to stay jakku and
don't let anyone tell you otherwise
right right why would they you told them
you were doing it yeah that's like
that's actually like when
people are saying well jack just go into
the hard drive and find the contract
where joe biden has
his name on it yeah with hunter biden
and jim biden we're just
just find the one where they lay it all
out man just find him like
dude why wouldn't i do that like unless
you're like a
jesse smallett level criminal right
right that's
it's like that scene in the wire and and
stringer bells like
are you seriously taking notes on a
criminal conspiracy
stop it like he just takes it from his
hands but that's that's what that's what
the
new york times wants unless they get a
letter where it's like
hi my name is joe biden my brother jim
is going to be taking money illegally
for me but my name won't be on it
sign this gym and that like you're not
gonna get a letter that spells it all
out that was actually the biden
administration's official response to
when the hunter biden
came out is like there is no official
meeting on his calendar like
well that makes sense right it wouldn't
be i would hope
you guys are at least competent enough
to try to hide your corruption right
secret meeting with ukrainian gas
executives i don't see it
then then girl scout awards yeah exactly
at 5 15. i mean it's they still kind of
did with like thanks for introducing me
to your father
you know letting us spend time together
or whatever or spending time together
yeah well
the one actually that i i try to get
back is
so why was it that all of hunter biden's
biggest deals
were in the countries where his father
was like the top diplomat
for obama right why is it that jim biden
got contracts for iraq
when when when biden when joe was the
one overseeing american operations in
iraq
so then his brother gets a contract to
build houses and makes millions of
dollars
so i wonder what that's all about just
just uh and i
it's cartoonishly obvious the new york
times had this story once i'll never
i'll never forget the wording um and it
was about harry reid and about how harry
reid had
made all of this money in the stock
market while he was a senator
and they went through this whole
uh investigation and the the phrase they
used was
he just had a knack yeah he just he just
had a knack
he hadn't hit a knack for buying stock
in the in the companies he's about to
deregulate just had a knack yeah just
just had a knack for knowing
right when to invest you know but i mean
i i've
read so many like articles and things by
leftists who
support like joe biden even when they do
kind of acknowledge the whole hunter
biden thing they try to distance it from
biden himself right this is just you
know yeah this might be bad but this all
just hunter doesn't really reflect on
biden himself i don't think what they're
understanding or what they're trying to
downplay is the fact that no it speaks
to biden's corruption right higg himself
like even if you say that all right
the the cash payment the 10 or whatever
that wasn't actually going to him
the fact that hunter biden was able to
get all of these jobs obviously there
must have been some sort of
quid pro quo right why what use is the
biden name for
if not to get something from i mean his
father at the very least
we know for a fact that hunter biden
flew on air force two with joe to china
to negotiate private equity deals
okay joe's corrupt end of story you can
throw everything else out the laptop can
go in the trash i don't care
how did it how did it happen where it's
like the u.s government
the vice president is paying to bring
his son to china for
private equity deals that is enough for
me
look i i complain when trump was having
military status golf courts and
everything
golf courses his resorts and he says i'm
saving them money and i'm like yeah that
may be true but still a conflict of
interest you shouldn't do it
trump actually backed away from the
doral thing when he wanted to do the g7
g7 yeah even conservatives are
complaining he's like okay fine we won't
do it i think it's dumb but whatever
joe biden just kept doing it over and
over again even if you
even if you say well joe himself wasn't
involved officially
i don't care he was using government
resources to send his kid to china for
equity deals
his kid was getting getting jobs hunter
biden admitted
do i think it was abc when he was asked
would you have gotten that job or not
for your name and he goes i don't know
probably not
so even he's like i know i'm only doing
this because we're pedaling influence
well and the the one that got them all
in trouble
the even more so was this tribal bonds
thing that blew up after joe left office
and so that's why guys like bevan cooney
are now behind bars that's why devin
archer is looking at time
it's it's because they when joe wasn't
in office anymore they started getting
their riskier ventures
and so the tribe even came out and said
look the only reason
that we signed this thing was because
there was a biden name on it and we
thought that was something that we could
trust
which i mean if you want to get into the
whole history
of like native americans tribes and
trusting
you know like i mean there's obviously
you know you can you can play that
threat out um i mean it's horrible like
you know people that's been you know
treated the way they have and
that's why this guy bevin cooney who's
now behind bars
did come forward to matt tiermann and
seamus bruner and peter schweitzer and
said look
i kind of feel like the fall guy here's
access to my gmail account i'm not using
it have at it go for it
wow and and that's i've literally sat
there just
you know i met we typed it in a hotel
room in chicago
and we type it in and there's this is
not the laptop or the hard drive or any
of that stuff
rudy is not involved it's just this
guy's gmail account and they said why
don't you leak it all i mean there's
like emails with his wife in there and
like like family stuff like you can't
just like drop all that like i'm yeah
i'd be responsible to do that
i think that's that's that's the
challenge because then no matter what
you do people are going to say what are
you leaving out right now
and so i mean what do you leave in it's
like if a guy's talking to his wife
about
some you know bed stuff personally it's
not necessarily relevant
yeah so then journalists have to go
through it the only problem i guess is
uh
how many journalists do we have left in
like in the in north america
i actually can confirm that uh copies of
the hard drive were distributed to some
some mainstream media journalists last
week and are they going to do anything
with it we'll see
yeah they know who they are and i'm not
going to call them out
um i don't think i know at least one of
them hasn't said
anything publicly yet so i'm not going
to you know i'm not gonna call people
out like that and i'm not gonna spill
that tea but do the right thing man
just do the right thing thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time